aujourd'hui on se parle de jo on se
parle de diouf parle d'une marque d'une
marque référence et jbl alors je vous ai
déjà parlé de gibel on est déjà regardé
des produits de j b hélas cette année on
voit arriver quoi un tout nouveau
produit de gibel qui est vachement cool
c'est là regardez c'est écrit noir sur
blanc blanc sont noirs facto noir sur
blanc ce sont les lie pro2 tws les
nouveaux écouteurs qui sont intéressants
qui font très jolies promesses on le
voit au niveau de la boîte on va avoir
regardé je vais tout vous dire à lc
active noise comme ça dit la réduction
proactive des appels parfait de la
recharge sans fil bref le truc est très
intéressant on va donc regarder si
aujourd'hui ces écouteurs de jbl sont
intéressants sont des intra vous allez
tout savoir accordez-moi quelques
minutes pour venir voyager dans le monde
merveilleux de jbl et voir ses écouteurs
sont potentiellement fait pour vous
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec jbl merci à
j belle tu es devenu sponsorisé cette
vidéo alors on va commencer par regarder
l'intérieur du packaging très rapidement
on voyage tak tak contrat en or
normalement vous avez ça à l'intérieur
et au dos vous avez vos petits écouteurs
qui apparaissent les emmys désinstaller
forcément ils sont plus là ensuite vous
avez à l'intérieur ici elle rendue très
rapidement on regarde et bien c'est un
petit peu tout ce qui va être nos petits
sacs wildstar deal la garantie si et ça
c'est cool c'est juste là on va voir ici
différentes tailles d'écouteurs du small
du large on a du médium qui a déjà
installé dessus ça c'est pour le côté et
si vous ouvrez de l'autre côté vous avez
un petit câble en usb c'est usb à
fournir les recharges et très rapidement
donc ça c'est plutôt bien alors après la
recharge et bien vous pouvez la faire
directement avec un câble c'est ce qui
globalement il ya le plus vite mais vous
avez également de la recharge sans fil
puisque ici on est compatible charge qi
donc si vous avez un chargeur sans fil
et bien vous allez les recharger c'est
plutôt bien mais vouloir jouer le plus
rapidement aux filières à savoir qu'ici
en 15 minutes de charge vous gagnez 4
heures d'autonomie alors puisque je vous
parle de l'autonomie on va aller jusqu'à
40 heures je dis bien jusqu'à c'est à
dire 10 heures par écouteurs sans
réduction de bruit active si vous
activez la réduction de bruit vous
descendez à 8 heures donc jusqu'à 40
heures puisque vous avez 30 heures avec
l'étui ça ça ne dépend absolument pas de
la réduction de bruit donc lorsque vous
écoutez pack tac vous leur posez vous
partez très longtemps et ça c'est cool
et là j'ai la voix commencent à partir
en cacahuète alors moi je dis qu'on se
parle de ses écouteurs en eux mêmes
écouteurs en eux mêmes ce sont des êtres
à garder un tracé court sur les petits
écouteurs vous prenez hop là via la
boutique atteint voter dans l'oreille et
vous la rentrée vous le positionner vous
le pivoter légèrement iront dans votre
oreille ça c'est le principe des intra
et ils nous ont fait un truc est quand
même assez sympa ici regardez venez voir
c'est qu'en fait vous avez un design en
forme de tige donc la tige elle est là
avec des petits tubes ovale je trouve
assez sympa très jolie super confort et
ça c'est quand même vachement bien vous
les prenez vous les tournées voulait
positionner alors il faut trouver tout
de suite la taille de lambour silicone
donc venez les essayer et vous allez pas
dans l'application et bien vous avez une
version test qui vous permet de savoir
s'ils sont adaptés à vos oreilles alors
l'application je vous la montre elle est
juste là et cjb l iphone vous appuyez
ici vous arrivez à directement là et là
vous descendez et vous avez une option
qui s'appelle vérifier mon maintien vous
appuyez sur vérifier mon maintien vous
lancer le test ça met de la musique je
l'entends à droite à gauche c'est très
très court et ça vous dira s'il
maintient est bon dans vos oreilles
alors comment il faut pas parler il faut
pas bouger et moi voyez il marque ici
bonne étanchéité à gauche et à droite
donc ça s'est très très bien donc on a
un très bon maintien on peut venir
bouger et bang est donc ça ça veut dire
quoi ce bon bouquin ça veut dire qu'en
fait ils seront vraiment adapté si vous
voulez aller faire du sport si vous
courez en extérieur ou en intérieur vous
faites du vélo vous pouvez venir les
prendre sans aucun problème attention ce
ne sont pas des écouteurs qui sont faits
pour aller dans l'eau on va éviter bien
que vous ayez une certification ipx5 on
va pas aller ce bac es avec peut le
savoir perso j'aime bien l'esthétique je
trouve que la boîte est plutôt de bonne
taille elle passe très bien dans une
poche facilement dans un sac les
écouteurs sont sympa en plus de ça vous
avez des petits commande tactile d'un
côté et de l'autre ici la voyez-vous
venait appuyer une fois deux fois trois
fois les appuis longue ça c'est un truc
classique qu'on connaît et que vous
voulez paramétrer également dans votre
application à le regarder je vous montre
on va venir ici dans l'application vous
revenez au pis si vous descendez en bas
et vous allez au niveau de ce qu'on va
appeler les mouvements alors vous
choisissez gauche et droite vous venez
de personnaliser c'est vous qui décidez
mois à gauche je me suis dit la commande
de réduction de bruit donc je touche une
fois je viens switcher entre la
réduction de bruit et le mode ambiante
were c'est à dire un mot doit venir en
temps ce qui passe autour de nous et
après je peux décider de la coupe est
directement si je le veux et ensuite le
double appui ça va être top sous activé
et tox ou désactiver et un appui long
sur voir mon assistant vocal natif donc
ça c'est pour la partie gauche et sur la
partie droite et bien je choisis
également ce que je veux alors moi j'ai
mis le volume j'appuie une fois ça
augmente le volume s'est appuyé deux
fois sa baisse le volume est fun a
depuis longtemps l'assistant vocal natif
ici puis c'est pareil pour les appelle
le double appui et l'appui loyalement et
après je peux dire complètement les
customiser je peux bien choisir ce que
je veut commander son bureau je les vire
à gauche comment du volume jallet à
droite pourra également un commandes de
lecture et de l'assistant ne rien mettre
du tout c'est à dire que si je décide
d'appuyer une fois lecture/pause deux
fois morceau suivant trois fois morceau
précédent et un appui long jeu mais
l'assistant vocal que je suis venu
choisir ici et je peux bien configuré
aussi très très facilement mon assistant
vocal donc la gêne assistant vocal natif
mais je peux également à voir amazon
alexa ou google assistants dont ça
dépendra bien évidemment de vous de ce
que vous aimez de l'expérience que vous
souhaitez avoir ici donc c'est quand
même très très cool je trouve que
l'expérience allait très chouette c'est
très intuitif vous appuyez d'un côté de
l'autre ça convient parfaitement bien et
là dessus aussi jbl à bien bosser alors
laisse vous le montre en noir il existe
dans différentes couleurs vous avez du
noir vous avez du bleu également et vous
l'avez en blanc comme ça il y en a pour
tout le monde je vous le disais quelques
instants de la réduction de bruit active
alors la réduction de bruit active s'est
coiffé pas moins de six micros à
l'intérieur et à l'extérieur et en fait
ce qui se passe c'est que pose écouteurs
convenir analysé le son en provenance de
l'extérieur pour venir le comparer avec
le son dans votre oreille et après on
sent un système de hors phase
c'est-à-dire que le son va venir là nul
est par exemple vous avez un signal up
qui monte et bien lui va venir faire un
signal descendante on les compare à zéro
il n'y a plus rien c'est le principe de
la réduction de bruit active mais vous
avez également une réduction de bruit
passive c'est pour ça qu'on a fait le
test tout à l'heure le test d'étanchéité
ça veut dire enfin que sa vie est tout
simplement vous boucher les oreilles
vous prenez ça bouge un petit peu ça
vous isole un petit peu l'extérieur ça
c'est le premier point et puis la
réduction bruit active tiendra en plus
vous couper un peu plus de l'extérieur
par ce système de hors phase mais gibel
a souhaité aller plus loin on à la
réduction de bruit active des larmes son
bruit passive on peut venir couper la
réduction de bruit active et le système
smart ambiance le smart un bien c'est
quoi ces vous prenez vos écouteurs et
les micros extérieurs vont venir injecté
leçon que vous avez de l'extérieur
directement à l'intérieur ça vous permet
d'entendre comme si vous n'aviez pas
votre cas ce jeudi bien comme si bien
que vous ne sentiez pas quasiment pas
parce que le confort et là vous avez
quand même un son qui vient des haut
parleurs sait pas exactement la même
chose quand son naturel mais ça marche
quand même très très bien ça c'est
vachement bien si par exemple vous êtes
dans la rue vous voulez joggé et vous
voulez vraiment entendre ce qui se passe
autour de vous si vous voulez écouter de
la musique vous allez traverser vous
voulez entendre les voitures pour ne pas
prendre de risques donc ce système là il
est cool mais si vous souhaitez de
couper toute l'électronique et bien
pouvait venir le faire également est
coupée ce soit la réduction de bruit
active ou le smart ambiance pourquoi
parce que toute l'électronique un moment
ou un autre ça vient moment j'ai un
petit peu de sont fatalement telle
électronique donc si vous voulez
profiter de la meilleure expérience
audio ou couper tout à côté de ça ça
marchera mais vachement bien alors moi
ce que j'ai bien aimé ce qui est très
cool sur très compliqué de vous faire
partager retour d'expérience ici on a
des transducteurs de 11 mm d'un côté et
l'autre ça ça me va bien c'est un grand
standard ça fonctionne mais on a le son
signature jbl et ce que j'aime bien avec
ce sont signature gbl c'est que je
trouve qu'on a des médiums qui sont
vraiment très doux voyez il ya un espèce
de côté un peu velouté un peu soyeux et
ce qui fait que lorsque vous allez
écouter j'écoutais des vieux morceaux
j'écoutais du ella fitzgerald par
exemple eh bien vous avez une voix qui
très suave une voix qui est très douce
et qui vient de se sont signature jbl
pour autant vous avez quand même des
basses profondes vous avez des graves
qui sont présents si vous le souhaitez
vous avez un équaliseur et j'ai vu
monstres ça dans quelques instants et
puis des aigus qui sont très présents
par exemple via un morceau que j'écoute
tout le temps lorsque je viens faire un
test eh bien je reconnais je retrouve la
cymbale il est arrivé sur certains
écouteurs que je ne retrouve pas ma
cymbales et ça ne va pas là je l'avais
massin balle ça me va bien donc on a
vraiment des yeux qui vont être très
précis donc on inspecte qui est large ce
qui fonctionne bien avec des graves
présent des médiums sûr très doux très
chouette et des élus présents et on a un
bon équilibre audio alors après ça va
bien évidemment dépendre de vous de vos
goûts et de ce que vous aimez écouter je
vous montre vous venez dans votre
application dans votre application vous
avez un système d'éco à l'isr ça c'est
plutôt bien que jbl à nous les mici par
défaut vous avez différents modes qui
sont prêts existants un mot jazz vocal
base club studio vous avez au dessus et
bien votre grave qui vous permet de voir
à peu près à quoi ça correspond on va
quand vocal on vient vraiment monter les
médiums et on casse un petit peu et des
raves en baston bayac du bassin le reste
c'est flat ce n'est pas forcément ce que
je vais aimer en club on vient flatter
un petit peu les bases sont bien creusé
légèrement les médium grave et les
médiums et ont bien monté légèrement
niveau des médiums aigus et des aigus
tandis qu'en studio on fracasse les
graves et on l'est tous flat et moi je
lui le personnaliser je me suis fait un
petit recul ce tome je suis venu
remonter un petit peu les graves
remonter un peu les aiguilles et j'ai
pas trop cassé ici les médiums alors le
truc a plutôt bien c'est que poignet
complètement le personnaliser le module
et vous par vous même voyez monde et
coalisation si par exemple je viens
monter un peu plus et bien je peux le
faire alors le truc que j'aime bien ici
au delà je veux dire on n'est pas des
ingénieurs du son c'est pas forcément
votre truc de se dire ok je veux dire
créer mon équaliseur mais si vous voulez
et si vous avez une oreille qui est
différente de celle des autres vous
voulez vraiment avoir une expérience qui
est customisé et bien vous appuyez sur
le petit plus là et là vous vous dites
ok je viens créer leur voyage et aux
deux extrémités je viens vraiment sur
l'un fera entre en deux même si j'ai pas
réellement d'un fera ici je vais jusqu'à
20 kg de l'autre côté même si je pas
réellement voir 20 kg en fait on dit ici
que j'ai eus plage de fréquences qui va
de 20 m à 20 km eh bien j'ai qu'à venir
poser mon doit aller par exemple je veux
venir monter un petit peu mais fréquence
je pose un doigt ici je mets là et là je
viens monter voiliers et ensuite je vais
faire ma pendre comme je le souhaite je
veux par contre il dire casser un peu
vers un kilo est bien employé hop je
viens casser un peu vers un kilo je dis
pas que c'est ce qu'il faut faire mais
pouvait le faire et voyez vous avez
votre fréquence en bas qui va venir sa
fiche et donc je trouve que le truc est
vachement bien fait je vois mon niveau
en décibels je vois ma fréquence c'est
très intuitif et c'est vraiment une des
meilleures expériences que j'ai pu voir
au niveau de la création ici donc là je
fais ça comme ça je vais venir et aussi
un peu vers 4 kilos parce que j'aime me
faire signer les oreilles et puis je
vois monter ici bonbons c'est pas
forcément ce qu'il vous faut je ne suis
pas du tout sûr c'est quoi lisant là
mais en tout cas on le fait vous appuyez
ensuite sur enregistrer ça vous le mets
ici dans mon égalisation de vous le
retrouver ça vous fait votre graff là
alors je ne dis pas que c'est ce qu'il
faut faire un temps sont vraiment pas pu
lui gratter là ça ne valait un peu plus
mais vous venez vous écouter vous mettez
de la musique et vous venez lire à tous
en même temps et vous écoutez les bandes
de fréquences et vous allez bandes de
fréquences par bandes de fréquence donc
ça je trouve ça cool c'est plus pour
l'utilisateur averti et si vous voulez
rester flat et profiter uniquement du
mix tel qu'il a été fait par à
l'ingénieur du son studio vous venez
couper les coins l'isr est comme ça vous
avez un son très flatté et ça ira très
bien et cette application alors quand
même pas mal de choses alors vous voyez
effectivement votre niveau de batterie
qui va paraître ici au niveau de vos
écouteurs et au niveau de votre coque de
votre petite caisse qui est là ou
choisissez votre réduction de bruit vous
pouvez la mettre réduction de bruit
l'homme bien peur qu'on va trouver là le
tox ou lorsqu'on veut venir parler
directement comme ça c'est plutôt pas
mal comme ça j'entends ma voix qui passe
à travers lorsque je discute et ensuite
vous pouvez venir personnaliser votre
réduction boury réduction de bruit
adaptatif qui va venir s'adapter en
fonction des bruits environnants autour
de vous compensation de suite
compensation du conduit auditif et vous
avez également un test de conduit
auditif pour sûr tout est bien
positionnée chez vous alors on l'a vu
les quoi l'isr vous avez ensuite
d'autres modes qui sont assez
intéressants c'est à dire un mode audio
et un mode vidéo intelligente vous aurez
compris truc si vous écoutez de la
musique mode audio et si vous vous pour
mettre un film une série vous switchez
sur le mode vidéo et je peux également
venir faire le choix de désactiver cette
partie là vos mouvements je vous ai
montré le world where qui est aussi
intéressant pour calculer niveaux de
voix que vous allez venir injecté plutôt
bien fait lecture pause automatique
l'assistant vocal ici il est natif mais
vous choisissez celui que vous voulez je
vous ai bon c'est tout à l'heure vous
choisissez votre langue moi je l'aimé en
français le maintien je vous ai montré
trouver vos écouteurs si vous les avez
perdu vous appuyer sa mettre un sou vous
êtes peinard l'économie d'énergie
remettre une veille automatique et un
arrêt automatique s'ils le souhaitent ok
pourquoi pas et puis si vous avez besoin
d'informations de conseils bonnes
pratiques vous avez un support ici avec
quelques informations la version de
votre logiciel s'il ya besoin de la
mettre à jour également dont je trouve
ça vachement bien fichu tout en sachant
et je vous le disais ici que vous avez
six micros à formation de faisceaux qui
vont notamment lors des appels
téléphoniques lutter contre le vent qui
vont bien maximiser l'expérience et puis
on en a un truc qui est bien c'est que
vous avez ici le google espère alors moi
ils sont déjà affairés à mon smartphone
mais lorsque vous les prenez vous ouvrez
il va vous le proposer en bas vous avez
qu'appuyer vous êtes connecté vous êtes
intéressé très rapide très pratique donc
là c'est très très bien c'est le premier
point et puis le deuxième point vous
avez le duel connexes et là vous pouvez
venir connecter vos écouteurs
directement à différents appareils par
exemple vous êtes sur une tablette
android quelle qu'elle soit vous
regardez un film une série d'un coup
votre téléphone sonne a sonné et bien
vous à pouvoir venir décrocher
directement avec votre téléphone et ça
va switcher automatiquement et dès que
c'est fini vous recrutez sur la table
est donc ça c'est vachement bien on a
ici du bluetooth 5.2 et sont des
écouteurs qui coûte 149 euros donc
extrêmement bien positionnée en tarif
donc si vous cherchez des écouteurs de
bonne qualité avec un audio qui marche
bien avec une expérience qui est
complète avec une belle application pour
venir gérer sondés quoi lire ce qui me
plaît plus quand même de reconnaître ici
des fonctionnaires est tactile qui sont
efficaces un très bon maintien vous avez
ici vous jbl life pro2 au tarif de 149
euros alors je les enlève comme ça qu'on
attendait un petit peu mieux parce que
depuis tout à l'heure ça ne bouge un peu
les oreilles mais voyons ces pratiques
aussi dites moi vous ce que vous en
pensez comment est ce que vous les
trouvez ces écouteurs de jbl est ce que
voulait trouver intéressant est ce qu'il
pourrait vous tentez est ce que vous
savez déjà eu des écouteurs de jbl alors
moi j belle sous le signe vieille
histoire parce que je sais pas si vous
savez mais moi je travaille dans le saut
dans le spectacle avant je parle de ça
il ya vingt ans et du connaissez jbl
parce que dans l'audio fatalement
gilbert peuvent pas passer à côté
l'expérience est là la qualité sonore
est là la signature jbl j'aime beaucoup
et vous le voyez une fois de plus ici on
se bien de jbl par ahmad n'est pas ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
à ce qu'elles pourraient vous tentez
bien évidemment s'il vous tente vous
mais un lien en bas dans la description
je vous laisse cliquer dessus pour en
savoir plus et découvrir et peut-être
peut-être allez savoir les acheter si
vous font de l'oeil je vous embrasse
pour lé soin de vous et à très bientôt
ciao